ça va samantha bonjour vous êtes
actuellement abidjan alors comment le
pays at il réagi à l annonce de la
commission électorale indépendante
c'est très calme ce matin abidjan la
circulation elle reste fluide même si ce
n'est pas le trafic des grands jours
dans la capitale économique
selon nos informations la situation elle
reste tendue toujours dans cette commune
populaire de yopougon kouté ou des
comités d'autodéfense en bloquent
l'accès à l'intérieur du pays
même chose situation tendue également à
tibi sous botro daoukro fief de
l'opposition là bas les populations
reste terrée chez elle et les magasins
sont fermés
alors ces résultats officiels du premier
tour de scrutin de la présidentielle ici
en côte d'ivoire on les a attendus à
très longtemps
hier soir ah c'est vrai que depuis
dimanche la commission électorale
indépendante a égrainé à les résultats
département par département en faisant
de très longues pauses et ce n'est
certainement pas un hasard si bien ses
résultats officiels ont finalement été
annoncées à l'aube presqu'un vers 5
heures du matin c'est probablement pour
éviter aussi les débordements les
résultats vous les avez détails et on
s'y attendait une victoire écrasante
pour le président sortant alassane
dramane ouattara 94 27 % des voix selon
donc la commission électorale
indépendante le président sortant qui
ont leurs appels n'avaient pas prévu de
se représenter
mais le décès brutal de son successeur
désigné et ancien premier ministre
amadou gon coulibaly a changé la donne
en tout cas
sa victoire elle doit être confirmée par
le conseil constitutionnel
maintenant pour les autres candidats
ceux qui n'ont pas voté et bien henri
konan-bédié a obtenu 1 66% des voix
pascal affi n'guessan à 0 99% des voix
pour le plus jeune de ses quatre
candidats en lice kouadio konan bertin
qui lui est allé déposer son bulletin
dans les urnes samedi dernier vient il a
obtenu 1,99 % à dévoyer un chiffre que
l'on attendait en tout cas on attendait
les tendances on ne les a pas du tout
obtenu ce chiffre c'est le taux de
participation dont qui a été livré cette
nuit également à 53,90 % des voix près
de 17000 601 bureaux de vote ont pu
ouvrir sur plus de 22 mille selon la
commission électorale indépendante
samantha est du côté de l'opposition
comment réagit-on après cette victoire
d'alassane ouattara alors le plus jeune
des candidats kouadio konan bertin lui
doit tenir ce matin une conférence de
presse on ne l'a pas beaucoup entendu
depuis la fin du vote samedi
pascal affi n'guessan et henri
konan-bédié ont annoncé hier la création
d'un conseil de transition civile avec à
sa tête le leader du pdc y un
gouvernement donc qu'il compte peaufiner
du coup on doit s'attendre encore
aujourd'hui à des déclarations
peut-être les invitations à des points
presse mais surtout les tensions
politiques elle risque de monter d'un
cran
ce matin j'ai pu joindre le porte-parole
adjoint du gouvernement ministre de la
jeunesse mamadou touré voici ce qu'il a
déclaré après l'annonce donc de la
formation de ce conseil de transition
nationale il évoque une provocation sans
essai de l'opposition il dit que nous
sommes dans un état de droit il s'agit
d'une provocation d'une opposition qui
veut masquer son échec un acte désespéré
ces initiatives tombent sous le coup de
la loi s'ils persistent ils devront en
assumer les conséquences
alors à l'as
dramane ouattara qui donc devrait
entamer un troisième mandat que
l'opposition juge anticonstitutionnelle
ne sais pas si il va vraiment tendre la
main à cette opposition si un dialogue
politique est possible mais on ne sait
pas trop non plus que vaut réellement ce
gouvernement de transition
en tout cas il semble que l'on
s'achemine vers une très longue crise
politique
à l'issue de cette élection qui risque
de paralyser le pays mais aussi la
population dans la crainte de violences
merci beaucoup samantha ramsamy
accompagné de claire nico pour toutes
ces précisions vous étiez en direct
d'abidjan en côte d'ivoire